I grew up in the 65 so she grew up with
Tina
so I live nearby I work at the dollar
once in a while she came and visit
so for me she has a special place in the
heart I often pass
her house here and then I will
already the last 10 years he's sick so I
was always hoping she will last long of
the day
she will live forever of course she's
just a great beautiful person the last
20 years
more than once we met all times in
restaurants at the same restaurant she
used to buy negro heirloomberg and five
years ago I was with my little child and
I saw the Rolls-Royce and I told him hey
this seems to be the car of Tina Turner
and then she opened the window and say
hi and smile I was so happy I was
shouting for happiness
and now she passed away it's really
sadly unexpected we knew she was sick
and she had withdrawn herself a little
bit from public life so obviously very
sad but not totally unexpected and I
just happened to be here I'm visiting
from the United States I grew up here
I'm living back going back to the States
tomorrow so for me I just wanted just to
stop by drop a flower and and that was
it you know
well she was
extremely positive powerful personality
she she lived life she loved to live
here and she was very open-minded
I mean all the stories you hear about
superstars they definitely didn't
fits to her I mean she was really very
natural and therefore I think that the
whole Community loved her you know when
she arrived her professional career as a
as a singer actually was was was
finished and she was looking for a place
where she could yeah live in freedom
without being
annoyed by by anything and I think
that's that's exactly what she found
here and about what she loved here and
she she wanted to become citizen of
krishnacht which was given to her and
she was very proud of that and I mean
then she she made as an example of the
nation of the the Christmas decoration
she uh she named our rescue boat after
Tina so really she was President she was
was Keen to to give give things back to
our community she is a worldwide
Superstar everyone recognized her on the
street but people didn't affect her by
taking herself he's asking for an
autograph or something like that she was
just able to to to enjoy enjoy her life
that the way he she wanted to do it